tout ce qu'on voulait faire c'était des
sacs réalisé l'interview présidentielle
je respecte la fonction présidentielle
il ya des responsabilités moi je suis
patron d'une entreprise aussi j'ai des
responsabilités lui lui il a été élue à
la tête d'un pays mais le fait d'occuper
des responsabilités qu'on respecte la
fonction n'empêche pas qu'on reste des
égouts on avait discuté absolument avec
jean jacques bourdin lui avais dis moi
tu sais je viens toujours comme ça
l'étoile du manant moi je fais mes
entretiens aussi sans cravate donc je
sais comme ça donc premièrement on vient
tel qu'on est
deuxièmement et je lui dis non c'est
froid que c'est jean jacques qui lit
mais alors comment on la paie et juillet
coûte moi je vais l'appeler emmanuel
macron voilà et donc on a convenu dit
ben oui moi je vais lui dire monsieur le
président au début mais après on
l'appellera emmanuel macron voila ca me
parait jeu
ce monsieur le président vous voyez déjà
on a pris plusieurs secondes de trop
déjà il manuel mâcon c'est un peu long
mais en fait c'est le côté oui on a
voulu on a voulu casser la différence on
a voulu casser la différence et je
respecte je me répète être tout en le
respectant justement est dans une
culture de l'égalité on a inventé la
république en bousculant le dogme de la
monarchie absolue
le dogme des privilèges le dogme de des
références aux monarques et donc oui moi
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent
depuis très longtemps et qu'ils ont
documenté par leur travail que nous
sommes démocratie de basse intensité car
nous sommes une monarchie républicaine
nous ne sommes pas un pays vraiment
démocratique
le président a beaucoup de pouvoir il
est beaucoup moins contrôlé que d'autres
présidents y compris le président des
états unis
le pouvoir ça c'est une question que
avait prévu le pouvoir du parlement est
très soumis au pouvoir exécutif
et donc oui j'ai moi je voulais marquer
ce symbole je dis moi je voulais une
interview d'égal à égal